ils sont partis de leur caserne en début
de matinée puis se sont rejoints sur les
différentes aires d'autoroute comme ici
à beaune en côte d'or
alors en tout ils sont 75 pompiers 75
pompiers de tout l'est de la france à
s'être rejoint ce matin il y a une
colonne soit douze camions citernes feux
de forêts plus bien sûr des véhicules de
commandement
alors ils partent tous en direction du
sud de la france à brignoles où ils
seront hébergés ce soir puis devrait
ensuite être répartis dans tout le sud
de la france en fonction des risques
d'incendié car ce risque d' incendies
justement il est plutôt important cette
semaine avec des températures plutôt
élevées et surtout du vent qui est prévu
alors tous ces pompiers ils devraient
arriver en fin d'après midi et à
brignoles et puis repartir en fin de
semaine